American Horror Story has never shied away
from tackling controversial topics.
The hit FX show will do whatever it takes
it torment, terrorize, and tantalize you,
and needless to say, things get extreme.
Here are some of the most controversial American
Horror Story moments of all time.
Season one of American Horror Story is full
of twisted violence that's become the show's
stock in trade ... but there's one moment
that's always stood out as particularly shocking.
In the episode "Piggy Piggy," we see Tate
Langdon — played by Evan Peters — carrying
out a school shooting and gunning down 15
of his fellow students.
“Dude, go!"
The on-screen massacre gave many viewers flashbacks
to the horrific tragedy at Columbine High
School in 1999.
After the episode aired, The Atlantic's Richard
Lawson wrote,
"It's more than a little tasteless in a 'Hey,
this, y'know, actually happened' kind of way.
Obviously everything on the show, if done
in real life, is insanely terrible [...] but
this particular set piece seemed so deliberately
exact.
There was a particular event, or events, that
they were trying to directly evoke and that's
just cruel."
Set in the 1960s, the second season of American
Horror Story takes us to the fictional mental
health facility Briarcliff Manor, and one
of its patients really outraged some viewers.
"What's your name?
I hear you caused quite a disturbance tonight.
Some anti-Semitic remark set you off."
In the episode "I Am Anne Frank - Part 1,"
a woman claiming to be Anne Frank shows up
at Briarcliff, and some people just weren't
having it.
Rolling Stone scribe Halle Kiefer wrote that:
"Next time we see her, the woman is writing
in her journal in the Briarcliff common room.
Because she’s Anne Frank.
Her journal is even named Kitty.
Oh lord, Anne Frank was a real person.
It just isn’t done!
Am I being too delicate about this?"
Some viewers argued that the show was never
trying to depict the real Anne Frank, but
rather a mentally ill woman who merely thought
she was Anne Frank.
Ryan Murphy worked that angle in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly, claiming:
"The Anne Frank thing was always interesting
to me because after the war […] there were
many women who came forward after that diary
and said, 'Well I'm the real Anne Frank,'
and they were struck down.
Many of them were found to be mentally ill
and suffering from schizophrenia."
Plenty of people took issue with a scene in
Hotel, the fifth season of American Horror
Story.
In the season premiere, a heroin addict named
named Gabriel checks into the Hotel Cortez
and soon suffers a terrible fate.
"You know what?
It's your lucky day.
Mama's feeling magnanimous."
Shortly after he gets to his room, Gabriel
has a horrific encounter with the Addiction
Demon, a monstrous entity with some sadistic
sexual appetites.
After watching the scene, Cosmopolitan's Danielle
Henderson was absolutely beside herself, writing
that,
"To say this scene was disturbing is an understatement."
Conservative watchdog group Parents Television
Council sharply criticized the episode, claiming
that,
"[It's an] unbelievably explicit combination
of sex and violence."
Honestly, it's hard to argue with that one.
In a letter to subscribers, PTC president
Tim Winter wrote that,
"[The episode features the] most vile and
shocking content I've ever seen on TV.
Ever.
Most Americans have no idea this is primetime
fare on advertiser-supported basic cable.
And everyone is paying for it as part of their
program bundle."
Who knew The Church of Satan could be so sensitive?
Members of the organization were reportedly
quite unhappy with the way the church's late
founder was portrayed on American Horror Story:
Apocalypse.
Known to his followers as the Black Pope,
Anton LaVey created the Church of Satan in
the swinging '60s, using the sexual liberation
of the day to his advantage.
His black masses could be unusually glitzy
affairs, attracting the likes of Sammy Davis
Jr., Liberace, and Jayne Mansfield.
Well, one particularly memorable scene in
American Horror Story: Apocalypse features
LaVey - portrayed by actor Carlo Rota - committing
a human sacrifice.
Suffice to say, some Satanists were seriously
steamed.
In a tweet posted to the Church of Satan's
official Twitter account, the organization
said,
"Anton LaVey didn't believe in Christ or an
Anti-Christ and sacrifice plays no role in
Satanism.
Lazy writers appropriated his name and image
for their Devil worship drivel [which] is
unimpressive and boring."
In the sixth episode of Cult — the seventh
season of American Horror Story — a crazed
cult leader played by Evan Peters stages a
massacre at his own rally.
"Drop the gun!"
It would be a divisive scene in the best of
times, but the episode aired shortly after
a real-life shooting.
On the night of October 1st, 2017, the deadliest
mass shooting in modern American history took
place in Las Vegas.
The AHS episode featuring the bloody rally
scene aired on October 10th.
In reaction to the tragedy, the violent sequence
was re-edited and significantly toned down,
but it was still a controversial moment of
television.
The night the episode aired, the AV Club's
Molly Horan wrote:
"The need to edit out a moment of violence
that now feels all too real is all the more
chilling when you consider Cult is acting
as a giant metaphor (and some could say, as
a giant mirror held up to) the post-election
era."
Yeah, this was a first.
Coven, the third season of American Horror
Story, featured what we'll go ahead and call
"a tender moment" between the witch Queenie
- portrayed by Gabourey Sidibe - and a Minotaur
Following the episode, the Daily Mail asked
its readership:
"Is this the most horrific episode of American
Horror Story yet?
Even die-hard fans left shocked as [...] bestiality
take[s] centre stage"
While that might be overstating it, the scene
is a bit much.
"You just wanted love.
And that makes you a beast?"
Even if Minotaur sex isn't your particular
cup of tea, perhaps it's best to keep an open
mind.
After all, it sounds like Sidibe was totally
down with the scene.
In fact, she told Parade magazine:
"I knew to say yes and to step out with faith
and trust in Ryan and his entire production
team.
I took the Minotaur by the horns."
Hey, to each their own, right?
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.